plus de l'automne une seconde ce
restaurateur était hors de lui ce matin
en fermant son commerce pour les dix
prochains jours
gluck
les gens circulent dans la rue les
supermarchés sont ouverts le grand métro
de moscou
alors qu'à l'intérieur de son restaurant
les employés emballe la vaisselle et v2
le garde-manger convaincu que le
confinement du raz des semaines et des
semaines car il faudra beaucoup plus que
quelques jours pour ralentir la pandémie
dont l'ampleur est ingérable
en moins de 24 heures
la russie a déploré plus de 1150 décès
est probablement le double si on se fie
au taux de mortalité officielle du pays
dans certaines régions les hôpitaux
confirment qu'ils ne savent plus comment
gérer leur morgue
où nous confient les morts dans des ça
et c'est carrément indigne
et pendant que la russie compte ses
morts hier ceux restant moscou a cru bon
de souligner la dernière soirée avant le
confinement avec une fête bien arrosée
il restera ferme pour de bon car on se
doute bien que le confinement sera
maintenue pour convaincre les russes de
se faire vacciner en masse pour
l'instant seulement 32 % le sont
seule façon selon elle de s'en sortir
c'est d'imposer un passeport vaccinale
des codes qr mais encore là dit elle les
gens en achètent des faux il n'a pas
fallu chercher très loin pour le
confirmer
quand nous avons demandé à ce médecin de
saint pétersbourg s'ils étaient vaccinés
comme quoi
il a répondu oui mais sur papier
seulement charles milhaud avait fait ce
qui fût maxi allo docteur oui et presque
tous les gens que je connais en ont un
ou ce même qu'un médecins et quatre
infirmières ont été arrêtés cette
semaine ils sont accusés d'avoir remis
aux gens des certificats de vaccination
tout en détruisant les doses non
utilisées
le problème ici c'est le système la
corruption il le je m'en foutisme des
gens dit il on s'en sortira pas
il n'a rien contre le roi
mais celui ci dit il c'est de la
foutaise
ici tu as marre alter escaut
radio-canada moscou